the consequences of liberal cities being
solved on crime on full display in
chicago we're now learning that the two
brothers charged with killing police
officer ella french are both felons one
reportedly on probation for robbery with
his sibling getting busted for theft
that comes amid another twist in the
story watch as the mother of the
brothers charged gets herself arrested
after trying to see one of them in the
hospital
i don't give a damn what people want to
hear i need to be a voice for my boys
and that's all i got to say let me get
in this hospital to see my son i want to
see my son
monty
don't touch
[Music]
me greg i'd like to hear screaming and
crying like that for the murdered police
officer from that woman we are
definitely in like a new era where you
see we see now all sorts of things
because of of this it's like you see the
mother go in who doesn't believe her
son's a murderer
this is part of that unstoppable march
towards reform
that because we like the sound of the
word reform and all of the practices
that smell of the past that stink of old
white men are inherently evil so we get
rid of you know cash bail we get rid of
we think prison is bad now
we let
felons out of jail in california
everywhere no one's being arrested for
grand larceny
so we we've not only threw the baby out
with the bath water we threw the parents
and the bathtub
in the in the quest for reform
so to use an analogy you know a semi
truck pulls into a dead-end alley it
can't turn around it can only go in
reverse there's no way forward for this
country we have to go backwards we have
to go and reverse and undo every one of
these idiotic decisions
ushered in under the lie of positive
reform no doubt there's good reform
we've seen it but a lot of this stuff is
based on some really wacky ideas from
wacky da's there are there been changes
in terms of how police officers in
chicago austin conduct business
what do you make of
everything that's happened in there now
in terms of the spike in crime what we
do know is that there is
one dead police officer one woman who
would have spent potentially decades
serving the city protecting the city
and she's gone
and was a great officer by all accounts
look i i live and work on the south side
of chicago i've been there 26 years
if somebody kills a police officer
absolutely they should be prosecuted to
the full extent of the law
i think
in
chicago as
in
much of the country the pandemic has led
to an increase in
both violent crime and non-violent
crimes
for some reasons we understand and some
some we don't
i think that's a separate issue from one
of the
controversies in the city of chicago
is that
the mayor has established a kind of a
civilian control of the police force
that they can investigate and
that was because of some pretty public
abuses on the part of the police
department i don't think there's
anything wrong with a basic proposition
which is let's go after criminals and
let's not have police officers abusing
their power and i think we can do both
of those things
if we're getting to a situation where
da's are going to pre-announce we will
not prosecute you we won't throw you in
jail for committing a crime i do think
you're going to get more crime and so
they they better think that throat yeah
but dana it's also the demonization and
the demoralization of police officers
led to a recruitment crisis not only are
people quitting the force but recruiting
is a problem because they these da's and
these mayors and governors will not lock
up criminals violent ones yeah they
won't back them up senator tom cotton
will probably make some
uh heads explode with his new op-ed that
he has a national review and the title
of it is our unite our national
under-incarceration problem and he's
making the case that there are actually
a lot of people who should be in jail um
and arguably these two might have been
two of them and also there's just a
total disrespect for the rule of law
total disregard for it if you look at
what happened in this situation they had
expired tax expired tags are a red flag
for police officers that's why they got
pulled over and before they could even
figure out what was going on in terms in
the car that's when they
shot them
so
when he talks about our under
incarceration problem i think there
might be
might be some merit to that well it's
certainly a problem here in new york
city that rikers island there are
thousands of prisoners who were let out
of rikers island with the plan of
closing it and with bail reform
again
right they're out uh violent criminals
are back out on the street that somebody
punches you in the nose brian you go to
the hospital they're not gonna they're
not gonna stay in jail not for an hour
uh they'll be out before you will yeah
because the emergency room that's the
case right i'm first in line okay thank
you i only have a minute left but just
just to add to this
in the chicago's unbelievable you see
it's emblematic of everything that's
wrong you have a parent instead of
saying oh my goodness my 21 year old and
my 22 year old are probably going to be
in jail for life and they're involved in
the murder of a cop and maybe a second
who got shot in the head who stole a
phone and got so upset that he was
drinking and driving and when he was
told to put down the drink he wouldn't
do it instead of the mom showing up say
how can my kids do that she comes up
vilifying the police it seems like on
the surface this 21 and 22 year old
never had a shot so you have how do we
stop crime today and then we how do we
stop another generation of killers be
and give them options before they become
teams before they realize that there is
more to life than the the life that
they're seeing around them somehow we
got to get into the inner cities into
the underprivileged communities and
provide some of the guidance that the
parents are not able to or are not just
doing but nothing nothing you've said is
new that's the problem right it's it's
the people in charge that what you just
said makes total sense but it's not
being done education sucks right we're
now killing every stan we're we're
killing standards on the street in the
schools
we are we are actually telling people
that we're in decline and we don't care
the the working class the uh the urban
class so many times need the best
teachers they get the worst because they
get paid the less to take the greatest
risk so they don't show up so somehow we
got to reverse that calculus and there's
a way to do it they do it in small areas
i love to see it bring into larger areas
because i think there's a lot of people
that want to solve this problem rather
than vilifying today they like to solve
it within five years give us a five year
program to get in and spread the
opportunity to people not the money not
the free lunches but the opportunity and
hope some of them are born and they have
no hope